for my latest mini election trick I'm
off to Mayfair in London to speak to
columnist Tim Montgomery about his new
project of the good right he's one of
the most influential conservative voices
in Britain so what is the background his
new project and what does he hope to
achieve
explain what you think is wrong with
conservatism leave Britain at the moment
well there's a lot that's right with it
the good right that I'm sort of
proposing at the moment isn't a
referendum revolution it's what I call a
Reformation I think it just conservatism
in a few respects needs reforming and if
casseras don't win a majority outright
at the next general election which I
think all the poll suggests is do you
agree do you agree with that yeah I
think the toys will struggle to win a
majority that means the last time the
Tories won a majority was 1992 charles
and diana was still happily married
nobody had internet in their homes not a
ball in the Premiership had been kicked
that's a long time for a party that was
probably the world's most successful
political party in the 20th century it
stopped winning elections something is
wrong so before we go on to what the
good right is that we have been here
before with the Cameroon modernisation
project which was very much focused on
policy exchange in 2005 and that have
ideas do you think Toa modernisation
failed or did they even exist to begin
with well there were some strengths of
what they become and did and I think
they focus on the National Health
Service for example was really important
people didn't believe the Conservatives
could be trusted with the public
services but a lot of the other kind of
modernisation that he pursued was almost
like trying to reach Guardian readers it
was trying to reach liberal hs2 same-sex
married same-sex about civil liberties
climate emphasis on climate change it
didn't address the fundamental Tory
problem which one of the opinion poll
says is that we're conservative seen as
the party of the of the rich is what
your elevator pitch of what the good
right is the good right is that actually
remind conservatives
the actually conservatism did begin in
1979 although Margaret Thatcher was a
brilliant Prime Minister I used to do
the rest of it this I had a poster of
her on my war when I was a student at
University in the late 80s but there was
a conservatism that existed before my
Harold Macmillan committed to house
building Winston Churchill for
industrial reform the factory conditions
conservatives have been willing to use
the power of the state for social good
and I think there's been a tendency
within too many conservatives to shy
away from almost any new activity new
state program because it's almost got
into their head that they're against the
state in all circumstances that
shouldn't be okay if we were sitting
here in 1981 wouldn't you've just been
labeled a Tory wet well I have been
called a Tory well then I'd I was
phrasing on Newsnight yes sir and I
think he is wrong because a lot of what
I proposed in the good right the left
would support so more Council house
building for example and then more
investment in infrastructure but the
only way that those things could be
afforded is by changing the priorities
of the state cutting back for example on
wasteful welfare spending stopping the
subsidy of low pay by employers the left
would just increase the power of the
state to do all these new things in
addition to everything it's already
doing but one of the differences for the
center-right perspective as well as
linking it to all traditional
conservative views on the family and
Europe and so on is that we believe that
not that the state should be bigger
overall it should just be doing
different things but you're not looking
at 2015 here the elections just a few
weeks or well months weeks away now
you're looking further into the futures
this were targeted for a future conserve
leadership what do you think David
Cameron might come around onside well
there's still the manifesto you know to
be published I understand there's some
big discussions going on behind the
scenes about potentially some quite bold
initiatives for blue collar Britain to
be included in that manifesto and I
certainly still hopeful that the next
Tory government elect
hopefully under David Cameron in May
will better Vance a lot of this to
that's it for this mini mini election
trip in London join me again soon to
find out more about how the general
election is being fought in a different
part of the country to find out more at
mini election code UK